hi i'm greg rosenthal and i'm going to
talk about interactive proofs for
synthesizing quantum states and
unitaries
which is joint work with henry ewan
first i'm going to talk about state and
unitary synthesis more generally and
then explain the interactive part
with state synthesis the goal is to
construct a quantum state
say given an encoding of that state as a
binary string in some reasonable way as
input and examples of states that one
might want to construct are quantum
money quantum pseudorandom states etc
with unitary synthesis the goal is to
apply a unitary transformation to a
given input register
and examples of unitaries that one might
be interested in are variational quantum
eigensolvers decoders for quantum error
correcting codes etc
and compared to what we know about the
quantum complexity of decision problems
relatively little is understood about
the complexity of quantum states and
unitary transformations in general
so why are these sort of problems hard
well they can be seen as quantum analogs
of function problems where with a
function problem the goal is to map an
input string to an output string
but there are at least three reasons
that the quantum versions are harder
first is that there's no clear reduction
to decision problems
whereas uh in a function problem
computing the output threatening reduces
to computing each bit of the output
string individually
which is a bunch of decision problems
but with uh quantum constructing a
quantum state the output qubits could be
entangled so it doesn't work to just
determine each output qubit individually
second because an n cubit state has two
to the n amplitudes it's in some sense
an exponentially more complex object
than a string
and finally in the case of the unitary
synthesis problem it's impossible to
even describe the output state given
unlimited time because the content of
the input register is unknown
in this paper we make progress toward an
analog of the ip equals p space theorem
for quantum states and unitaries
and what do i mean by this we define
quantum state and unitary analogues of
well-known complexity classes such as
p-space and qip
we prove that state p-space is contained
in steel state qip and as a partial
converse we prove that state qip is
contained in state x
we also proved that a certain special
case of unitary p space is contained in
unitary qip
and we also obtain similar results with
multiple entangled proofers
these results are of course analogous to
qip equals p space and mip star equals
re
and in fact reduced to these results as
subroutines but i want to stress that
the reductions are non-trivial as we
will see
so first let me define some of these
classes the model of the interaction
that we consider is as follows there's a
bqp verifier that interacts with an
untrusted quantum prover over many
rounds and the messages are allowed to
be quantum
then the verifier accepts or rejects
which so far is exactly like the model
of computation in the complexity class
qip
and then finally and this step is
different
when the verifier accepts it output it
also outputs a quantum state
and the completeness and some
discurrencies that we want to enforce
are as follows
for completeness there should exist an
honest prover strategy such that with
probability one the verifier accepts and
the output state is approximately what
it's supposed to be
and for soundness
for all prover strategies such that the
verifier accepts with non-negligible
probability the verifier's output state
condition on accepting should be
approximately correct
more precisely what i mean by
approximately here is as follows so for
state synthesis
when the um
prover is honest the output state is
correct with an exponentially small
error in trace distance
and uh
for soundness when the verifier accepts
with probability any more than
exponentially small the verifier's
output state condition on accepting for
that proven strategy is correct within
polynomially small trace distance error
for unitary synthesis we have similar
guarantees except that when the proofer
is honest the output state is only
correct within polynomially small trace
distance error
so here are the classes that we define
state qip is the class of sequences on
cyan n with cyan on n qubits that can be
synthesized as above
where generally one could consider state
families indexed by binary strings
rather than natural numbers it doesn't
really make a difference we just need to
consider some infinite family of states
that we can use asymptotic notation
and similarly the requirement that psi
and b on exactly n cubits isn't
important it could be polynomial and
then and their results would still hold
unitary qip is defined similarly but
with unitaries rather than states
state p space it's
the class of
state families that can be constructed
in quantum polynomial space
and
for purposes of this talk you won't need
to actually know what we mean by quantum
polynomial space but it's defined on the
next slide in case you're curious
then finally the definition of unitary p
space is similar
so here's what i mean by quantum
polynomial space well we say that cnn is
a family of quantum polynomial space
circuits if these three conditions hold
first there should exist a p space
machine that on the all one's input
outputs the description of c sub n
second
c sub n should consist of the following
types of operations uh first it's
allowed to apply gates from a universal
gate set a second it cannot measure
qubits in the standard basis
third it's allowed to trace out qubits
and fourth it's allowed to introduce new
qubits initialized to the zero state
and finally we require that at any given
point in the execution of cn it uses at
most poly and qubits
which is why tracing out qubits above is
important
so first let me talk about the proof of
state p space and state qyp now and then
i'll talk about the proofs of the other
results
as an easier problem or as a warm-up
let's consider state synthesis with a
trusted prover but assuming that prover
is only allowed to send classical
messages
and uh the solution to this problem is
due to aronson now we can construct an
arbitrary quantum state in this model in
polynomial time as follows
first let's read the target states psi
as bit is zero
zero cubit and some state theta zero
plus beta one the one cubit some states
theta one
uh then the verifier will uh query the
values of beta0 and beta1 to finite
precision the more bits of precision the
lower the error uh to get exponentially
small error it suffices to query the
bits of position
then the verifier will construct beta0
plus beta 1 1
let's say for future reference in a
register that we'll call r
then the verifier will uncompute the
values of bit 0 and beta 1. again by
calling the oracle i'll explain why this
is important later
and finally controlled on the bit i in
that previously mentioned register r the
verifier recursively constructs theta i
which will yield psi
so why is it important important to
uncompute beta0 and beta1
well at the outermost level of
recruitment it doesn't really make a
difference but otherwise
if we don't uncompute the garbage then
if uh we write the target state psi as
some overall ambit strings x of alpha x
x uh if we don't uncompute the queries
we would
instead result output the first n qubits
of sum x alpha x x uh some garbage state
depending on x which is not what we want
to do
so now how can we transfer this uh or
convert it to a protocol with an
untrusted prover but who's allowed to
send quantum messages
well
for states that are in state p space it
turns out that the queries from the
trusted prover protocol can be computed
in p space
and we prove this using p space equals b
q p space and algorithms for quantum
state tomography
so this yields the idea what if we run
the trusted prover protocol but answer
the queries using the ip equals p space
protocol in superposition
and the issue with this like it does not
you know prevent against a certain
attacks by the prover in the forward
direction the issue is uh when in the
step where we uncompute the queries
you know where we run i p equals p space
in reverse essentially which we need to
do
because then we need to make sure that
uh the prover also uncomputes honestly
so for example here's a one attack that
the approver might do on this protocol
let's say it's uh for example honest
until the very last round
uh uh it's honest in the forward
direction of ip equals p space in the
last round
but then controlled on the the classical
string x it confirm it constructs some
state fie sub x in private
and then it uh which it's not supposed
to do and then after that it just
uncomputes as normal then the verifier
would output the first n qubits of the
state sum max alpha x x v x where v x is
held by the prover
and that's not the same as outputting
psi
so how do we fix this
uh first let me introduce some notation
uh
let ci sub k denote the k qubit state
that the verifier obtains after k
iterations of the trusted prover
protocol
so for example psi sub n is the target
state that we want to construct
and size of zero it's just like the zero
cubic state
uh given two copies of size sub k let's
call them copy one and copy two uh
here's a procedure that will allow the
verifier uh to obtain two copies of psi
sub k plus one in a verifiable way and
then by doing this for k all the way up
to n that's how the verifier obtains the
target state
so the verifier will first flip a coin
and it's very crucial that this coin is
flipped in private the approver does not
know what a value this coin is we'll see
why that's important later
if the coin comes up heads the uh
verifier will do a procedure described
on the next slide that should ideally
yield two copies of side k plus one if
the proof is honest that is
and if the coin comes up tails the
verifier will do a procedure that should
just uh
ideally end up back where the where the
verifier started with two copies of psi
k but might detect dishonest behavior by
the prover in the meantime which is the
point of this and then we just keep the
verifier keeps flipping coins like this
until one of them comes up heads which
and that's how we progress inside k plus
one
so now let me go into more detail here
in the heads case the verifier will
simulate a round of the trusted prover
protocol on copy one
which i recall that this should yield
side k plus one if the prover is honest
then
let's say uh the approver was honest uh
um
then when we request a second copy of
psy k plus one from the approver and do
the swap test no the swap test will pass
and the approver is forced to be honest
in sending that second copy of psi k
plus one here
if it was
honest so far
because otherwise the swap test would
detect these two states are different
now for the tails case
the verifier is going to start off by
behaving exactly like it would in the
heads case as far as approver can tell
i.e it simulates round of the trusted
prover protocol on copy one
but the prover or sorry the verifier
just leaves out the step in the middle
that grows the state by a qubit i recall
that i mean uh this highlighted step
right here and if we leave out this step
then everything is just uncomputed and
so it should yield psi k back again
that's if the prover uncomputes honestly
but if the prover doesn't uncompute
honestly the resulting state will be
different from psi k
so then when the verifier does the c
swap test with this uh copy 2 that we
had
originally
it'll detect that the approver was
cheating
so to recap the
the tails case it forces the prover to
behave honestly when uncomputing and
since the prover doesn't know whether
it's tails or ted's heels or ted's until
after it's over that forces the approver
to be honest in general essentially
now this protocol will work but with a
weaker soundness guarantee than we would
like so we
finally amplify the sadness of the
protocol as follows we execute that
protocol polynomially many times if any
one of those executions reject then we
know the prover was dishonest and we
reject and otherwise the verifier will
accept and output the output state of a
uniform random one of these executions
and the intuition here is that it gives
the verifier more opportunities to
detect the prover cheating
now i'm going to go over the proofs of
these other results
first the inclusion of state qip and
state x
uh the state x machine will find an
approximately honest prover
for the state qip protocol by optimizing
over an sdp
the variables in this stp will be the
density matrices held by the state qip
verifier at the beginning and end of
each round the constraints in the sdp
will enforce that the start state is
correct uh the transitions between
rounds are legal and the end state is
accepted with high probability
which uh
this uh
argument is analogous to the original
proof that qip is contained in x
and then once the state x machine has a
description of an honest approver for
the state qip protocol it can simulate
the state qap protocol with that prover
resulting in the the output state of the
same qip protocol
now for a special case of unitary p
space contained in unitary qip
we say that an n qubit unitary u as
polynomial action if u acts
non-trivially on a subspace of dimension
at most poly n
and uh this has approved using a
hamiltonian simulation algorithm so more
precisely if we write the unitary u as e
to the i t rho
where t is some time and rho is a
density matrix well we and if
u is in unitary p space
then we can show that a certain
purification of rho is in state p space
so using the inclusion of state p space
instead q i p which we previously proved
the verifier can obtain copies of rho
and additionally the evolution time t of
this hamiltonian which are that it's
computable in p space so using its p
space equals q i p
the verifier can obtain the value of t
and then given t and given copies of rho
uh implementing uh u can be done using
this hamiltonian simulation algorithm
so where do the where does the
polynomial action assumption come in uh
if we assume that u has polynomial
action then the evolution time of this
hamiltonian is at most polyend and this
is necessary for the hamiltonian
simulation algorithm to be efficient and
uh to require at most a polynomial
number of copies of rho
now here are the analogous results with
multiple entangled provers we define
state r as the quantum state analog of
the class r of computable languages
and this is the class of state sequences
one on each number of qubits such that
uh descriptions of exponentially good
approximations of these states are
computable as a function of
n
and i'll explain why it's not state re
in a moment and when we prove that uh
state r equals state q and i p
so for the inclusion of state r and
state q and i p
it's just like the proof of state p
space and state q i p that we previously
went over
but using mit star equals re in place of
ip equals p space
then for the reverse inclusion of state
qmip and state r
and
this is done by brute forcing over all
provers until an honest prover comes up
and then given an honest prover just
simulate the state qmid protocol to
construct the state
and this is where the quantum state
version of the statement is not directly
analogous to the decision problem
version of this statement why it's
because if you try to prove that
r equals uh mit star using similar
reasoning which is a false statement
and
but if you tried to prove it using uh
this reasoning the problem would be that
the search would fail to terminate for
strings not in the language but by
assumption
like by the nature of our model we just
assumed that an honest prover exists so
the search always terminates
and finally
using similar reasoning we proved that
quote polynomial action unitary r is
contained in unitary qmip
open problems there are a lot
uh first
recall that we proved state qip is
contained in state x but can we improve
that the state qip is contained in state
p space
which would imply you know a complete
quantum state analog of the ip equals p
space theorem
second uh some of the errors on our
results were polynomially small can we
improve them to exponentially small
can we reduce the number of rounds in
our protocols all of our rounds have a
polynomial number of rounds but can we
get it down to constant
we do
propose constant round variance of our
protocols that we conjecture to work but
we haven't proved that they work
is it the case that unitary p space is
contained in unitary qip
not just that polynomial action unitary
p space is contained in unitary qip
can we generalize our protocol to
construct mixed states rather than just
pure states
what about state and unitary synthesis
if we require the approvers to be
efficient
currently our protocol requires the
approver to solve problems in p space
what if
we consider multiple unentangled provers
in rather than multiple entangled
proofers interestingly some of our
results break down if the provers are
unentangled in particular soundness
amplification and the tomography step
and finally is there an interesting
notion of zero knowledge for uh quantum
state and unitary synthesis nor their
crypt
cryptography applications
thank you